Democrats love to portray themselves as
the party of love and tolerance but are
they we just showed y'all how Chuck
Schumer threatened to sitting Supreme
Court justices and while Schumer wasn't
making a physical threat others in his
party have openly threatened violence
against the president
Donald Trump is a guy who you understand
he hurts you and you in my testosterone
sometimes makes me want to feel like
punching him in high school I could take
it behind the gym but I think you need
to go back and then punch him in the
face aren't they lovely joining me now
are congressman Matt gates and Lee
Selden congressman Zeldin does that
sound like a party of love and tolerance
to you no not at all and as your plane
and I'm thinking of Steve Scalise who
almost lost his life all of the other
members Republican members of the House
in the Senate who would have lost theirs
if not for the great work of the Capitol
Police I remember the end of June of
2018 Maxine Waters
was speaking to her supporters with a
video that went viral and she was using
a lot of rhetoric about confronting
Trump administration officials to
confront them in public places in
restaurants and movie theaters well
guess what the first week of July of
2018 I had one of my campaign volunteers
a strong supporter of Donald Trump
Donato Panico was targeted by somebody
who was using the same exact rhetoric
and almost killed this campaign
volunteer of mine with his car I give
think I'm stories from 17 from 18
fast-forward to today we're not sending
the right message not only as the
leaders who share this hyperbolic
rhetoric but all the followers who then
look at it as a call to arms and the
obviously the Antipa thugs of the over
the course of all these years
congressman gates I mentioned state
senator Katrina Jackson who was
subjected to this sort of thing for her
pro-life stance have you been subjected
to anything like this or your SIA yeah
we've had a number of very frightening
death threats that involve you know
taking shots at me from long range and
it's sometimes a double standard with
the FBI on what they're willing to
investigate and what they're not based
on whether or not you're conservative in
my experience you have to ask the
question what is animating this hatred
on the left
I think it's the fact that they're
losing Donald Trump has reshaped the
federal judiciary it is one of the
enduring legacies of his presidency
Chuck Schumer lost on merit garland he
lost when he tried to block Gorsuch and
they lost in spectacular fashion when
they tried to ruin the life of justice
Cavanaugh and so now with I think
resurgence of a conservative judiciary
you see the folks on the left even more
anxious and even more unpredictable
Democrats have been saying for years
that Trump is the violent one watch what
mr. Trump has done is create an
atmosphere that condones violence that
actually incites people's most emotional
and violent feelings I told the
president directly that I thought his
language about enemies of people was not
just divisive but increasingly dangerous
that is the language of despots in other
countries and and it is dangerous from
the president congressman Zeldin did
Maggie Haberman or Bruyne Staedtler did
any of them condemn what Schumer said
yesterday not that I know of and that's
one of the things that's so frustrating
at all the double standards the moral
equivalency that we've seen since Donald
Trump has gotten elected and we saw it
last year in the House of
Representatives with all the
anti-semitic rhetoric that was coming
out of new members elon Omar and Rashida
to leave is a double standards and the
moral equivalencies I also say this you
know we settle our scores at the ballot
box and all right this inflammatory
rhetoric it belongs there and has a
consequence of the last presidential
election that's how you end up with Neal
Gorsuch that's how you end up with Brett
Kavanaugh let us do our jobs but
certainly T as you point out whether
you're in Congress you're a member of
the media call balls and strikes
accurately if you want to go there and
right here Senator Schumer it was a
threat
there's no acceptable excuse there's no
acceptable explanation for it but you
can't cut it any other way it was a
threat well as congressman gates was
saying I think he fears losing at the
Supreme Court on the merits of this case
and he wants to protect that I want your
reaction to this the coronavirus
yesterday the New York Times reported
that quote on Monday the CDC appeared to
have removed figures on the agency
website counting how many Americans had
been tested
engaged very quickly and they told
Congress why they're doing this yes
because we have democratized access to
testing to the state level we're
actually doing a great deal more testing
now and so keeping that data in real
time on the CDC website is less
productive than having States do the
testing and do the reporting congressman
thank you both which I had more time
we'll catch up with you soon